police versus the people
on the streets of colombo
[Applause]
protesters who've come out in their
thousands have no fear
angry defiant
committed to removing the country's
leaders
[Applause]
later show of rage against the people
they blame for creating sri lanka's
economic nightmare
sri lankans want president gotabaya
rajapaksa gone for good and he has fled
the country
it may be the end of the rudger pack
says in sri lanka but that's not enough
for this crowd they say they want the
prime minister out too and they'll keep
protesting until he's gone
they want to get inside the prime
minister's office and we'll stop at
nothing because there's nothing to lose
we actually don't have a future in this
country how it's going to face in if
this continues like this actually
there's no future for anybody in this
country
[Applause]
a state of emergency declared the
military given power to get colombo
under control
the protesters briefly took over state
tv telling the nation they haven't
caused any damage urging people to
support their struggle
a struggle they're winning
taking control of the prime minister's
office a fourth government building
occupied
sri lanka's politicians no match for the
power of the people
bad people the politicians kill our
country we don't have any ethnic issues
any religious issues we are united we
are stopped we are lonely people
from street battles to songs
chaos and carnival in equal measure
a revolution like no other
the people are in control for now
a political dynasty has fallen
and while this situation drags on
there can be no solution to sri lanka's
economic misery
nicole johnston sky news colombo